*prustet*
*Musik*
Freunde der Sonne, mich erreichte
eine entzückende Frage per Mail.
Ich lese vor.
Hallo, ich habe eine Frage
an schönschlau.
Ein Kind meiner Hortgruppe,
sechs bis zehnjährige Kids,
stellte mir eine interessante Frage.
Wenn man, so Jakobs Frage, in
einem Lift wäre, der abreißen würde,
könnte die Person Verletzungen
vermeiden, wenn Sie vor dem Aufprall
hochspringen würde?
Andere Kinder wandten ein, dass man
nicht wüsste, wann man aufprallt,
und dass Lifte auch
durch Seile gesichert seien.
Ja, so Jakob aber,
wenn es denn ginge.
Erst mal Gabi, deine Kids
sind ganz schön schlau,
denn 1. sind Aufzüge tatsächlich
nicht nur durch mehrere Stahlseile,
sondern auch
durch Bremsen gesichert.
2. haben Sie ein großes Problem
direkt erkannt, nämlich,
wenn ich nicht weiß, wann ich
aufpralle, woher soll ich wissen,
wann ich springen soll?
*aufgeregtes Atmen*
Aber lassen wir das mal außen vor,
Jakob möchte schließlich wissen,
was theoretisch
physikalisch möglich ist.
Nicht wahr, Jakob?
Also im Prinzip geht es darum, die
Härte des Aufpralls zu verringern.
Die Härte des Aufpralls setzt sich
zusammen aus der eigenen Körpermasse
und der Fallgeschwindigkeit,
die man dann kurz
vor dem Aufprall hat.
Die Fallgeschwindigkeit hängt
davon ab, wie lange wir fallen,
bzw. aus welcher Höhe wir fallen.
Machen wir es uns einfach,
wir vernachlässigen jede Reibung
und gehen von einem freien Fall aus.
Würde ich mit dem Fahrstuhl
von der Aussichtsplattform
des Berliner Fernsehturms abstürzen,
dann würden der Fahrstuhl und ich
mit einer Geschwindigkeit
von fast 230 km/h am Boden ankommen.
Ja, wenn man mit 230 Sachen
in den Boden gefahren wird,
dann... Aua!
Aber selbst aus einer Höhe
von nur 10 m kommt man immerhin
auf eine Geschwindigkeit
von etwa 50 km/h.
Also immer noch gefährlich genug.
Fahr mal mit 50 km/h gegen eine
Wand, aber ohne Sicherheitsgurt,
ohne Airbag, einfach nur
in einer Kiste.
Also sagen wir, ich würde just im
richtigen Moment eine halbe Sekunde
vor Aufprall hochspringen,
würde das funktionieren?
Äh, naja...Sprungkraft gehört nicht
zu meinen persönlichen Stärken.
Aber selbst die
Sprunggeschwindigkeit von Athleten
kommt nicht ran an die
Geschwindigkeiten vom freien Fall.
Möglicherweise könnte man die
Aufprallgeschwindigkeit um 5 km/h
verringern, mehr aber auch nicht.
Darüber hinaus befinden wir uns
im freien Fall in Schwerelosigkeit.
Und in Schwerelosigkeit
ist es nicht leicht zu springen.
Normalerweise ist es so, dass man
vor dem Springen in die Knie geht.
Man beugt seine Gelenke
und durch die Schwerkraft
behält man Kontakt mit dem Boden,
von dem man sich abdrücken kann.
Nicht so, wenn der Boden
mit dir fällt.
Ingenieure vom MIT empfehlen, dass
man sich bei einem Aufzugabsturz
flach auf den Rücken
auf den Boden legen sollte,
damit man beim Aufprall,
den Impuls auf eine möglichst
große Körperfläche verteilt.
*stöhnt angespannt*
Aber wie beim Abspringen,
ist es in Schwerelosigkeit
gar nicht so einfach,
sich auf den Boden zu legen,
wenn der Boden mit dir fällt.
Außerdem hat man
nicht gerade viel Zeit dafür,
denn selbst ein Sturz
vom Berliner Fernsehturm
würde weniger als 7 Sekunden dauern.
Und noch eine Sache
mit diesem flach hinlegen...
Einerseits ist die Wirbelsäule
in einer günstigeren Lage
für den Aufprall,
wenn der Körper waagerecht liegt.
Andererseits ist der Schädel so
wahrscheinlich schneller Matsch.
Vielleicht würde ich
dann doch lieber stehen bleiben,
beide Beine und Hüfte brechen,
mit der Hoffnung
auf einen unversehrten Kopf? Hm,
naja Wirbelsäule ist auch wichtig.
Das sind aber Überlegungen,
die wir uns in der Praxis
nicht wirklich machen müssen.
Die Wahrscheinlichkeit
mit einem Aufzug abzustürzen
ist kleiner
als ein Sechser im Lotto.
Ansonsten ist Treppensteigen
sowieso gesünder.
Auch wenn da garantiert
mehr Unfälle passieren.
Schön schlau!
Untertitel: ARD Text
im Auftrag von Funk.
Vielen Dank an Gabi und Jakob
und den schönschlauen Hort aus Wien.
Wenn ihr Fragen habt,
schreibt sie in die Kommentare.
Wenn ihr Lust habt auch
rumzurechnen, welche Geschwindigkeit
ihr aus welcher Höhe
erreichen würdet,
die Formel steht
in der Videobeschreibung.
Bis nächsten Donnerstag.
Bleibt sicher!